le château de versailles organisera le
mois prochain une séance exceptionnelle
de son spectacle des grandes eaux
musicales dont la recette sera
intégralement destinés à la replantation
du parc la tempête du mois de décembre
détruit vous le savez plus de dix mille
arbres
la saison des grandes eaux musicales a
redémarré aujourd'hui nathalie et terre
et benoît vers en sont descendus sous
terre à la découverte de bien
mystérieuse canalisations versailles
trois siècles d'histoire trois siècles
de mystère ici on est loin des lambris
dorés et des miroirs de la grande
galerie sous les halles et les bosquets
les bassins du parc c'est un incroyable
labyrinthe que les ouvriers du roi
soleil avait bâti on le voit c'est que
les petits boudins m prendre une
cuillère de par certains qui vont copé
sud côté d'or
surtout les verts y vivre en 35 km de
canalisations arpenter depuis 24 ans par
roger à quelques heures du coup d'envoi
des grandes eaux c'est l'ultime
vérification pour que deux matches
la rouille n'a en rien entamé la
solidité du système ya parfois des
fuites c'est vrai mais elles sont
régulièrement colmatée désormais tout
est fin prêt pour le grand spectacle à
50 fontaine 1200 g et douze mille mètres
cubes d'eau
tous
louis xiv à prendre dans tout son règne
a une obsession c'est la ressource en
eau donc il avait à sa disposition à peu
près deux fois et demie plus de gedo que
maintenant donc on avait un
fonctionnement extravagant et qui était
tellement extravagant qu'il était
impossible de faire fonctionner tous les
jets d'eau à la fois douze heures de
spectacle et un savoir faire qui de
génération en génération a permis aux
fontaines et de versailles de restituer
intacte la magie du grand siècle